lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
practicar cómo encontrar soluciones
generales para ecuaciones diferenciales
separables digamos que tenemos una
ecuación diferencial de de x la derivada
de ye con respecto a x es igual a a la x
entre y traten de encontrar la solución
general para esta ecuación diferencial y
les doy una pista enorme es una ecuación
diferencial separable al trabajar con
ecuaciones diferenciales separables lo
que queremos hacer es tener las 10 y las
leyes en un lado y a las x de x en el
otro lado es algo parecido a tratar
estas diferenciales como si fueran
variables lo cual es muy útil con las
matemáticas vamos a hacerlo si
multiplicamos ambos lados porque que
vamos a tener ya por la derivada de ye
con respecto a x igual a a la x y ahora
vamos a multiplicar ambos lados de la
ecuación por la diferencial de x estas
se cancelan y nos queda y por dg iguala
a la x x de x
ahora vamos a calcular la integral en
ambos lados cuál es la integral de i d y
aplicamos el inverso de la regla de la
potencia incrementamos el exponente y
dividimos todo entre este exponente
incrementado ya al cuadrado entre 2 esto
es igual a cuál es la integral de a la x
de x lo genial de la ala x es que su
derivada y su anti derivada son
exactamente lo mismo esto es igual
a a la x + c podríamos dejar esto así si
quisiéramos de hecho esto así como ésta
no es una función explícita ya no es una
función explícita de x podríamos decir
que es igual a más o menos la raíz
cuadrada de a la x más c entre 2 pero
ésta es una ecuación bastante general
que satisface esta ecuación diferencial
separable hagamos otro ejemplo digamos
que tenemos la derivada de con respecto
a x que es igual ayer al cuadro
por ser de equis pausa en el vídeo y
traten de encontrar la solución general
nuevamente queremos separar nuestras yes
y nuestras x podemos multiplicar ambos
lados porque a la menos 2 y también
podemos multiplicar ambos lados por de x
la ponemos aquí se cancela con esta la
ponemos también por acá nos queda allí a
la menos dos por igual
x b x finalmente integramos ambos lados
cual es la anti derivada de al menos 2
de nuevo usamos el inverso de la regla
de la potencia incrementamos el
exponente por lo que nos queda ya a la
menos uno y dividimos entre el exponente
incrementado que es menos 1 con lo que
esto nos queda negativo esto va a ser
igual a cuál será la anti derivada de
seno de x podrán reconocerlas y pongo un
signo menos aquí y otro signo menos acá
la anti derivada de menos seno dx es
coseno de x x
todo esto es igual a menos coseno de x
otra forma de escribir esto es
multiplicar ambos lados por menos 1 y
nos queda 1 entre james es igual a
coseno de x y casi se me olvide escribir
la constante ponemos más o puedo tomar
el recíproco de ambos lados si quiero
tener la función explícita para ayer y
nos queda
igual a 1 entre coseno de x más c esta
es nuestra solución en general y con
esto terminamos